hey guys I'm back in this video we're
gonna talk about the six natural ways to
lower cortisol okay now what does
cortisol cortisol is a really important
hormone that you really need a certain
amount of it but we don't need too much
and we don't need too little of it if
it's too little we're going to have
inflammation a lot of immune problems if
it's too much we're gonna have a lot of
other additional issues including stress
states in the body blood sugar issues
high blood pressure a whole bunch of
other things okay but cortisol if it's
too high is very destructive on the body
on the aging process it breaks down your
collagen it makes you look older so we
want to keep that we want to bring it
down to a normal level a lot of people
have too much cortisol and it interrupts
their sleep
so there's actually six ways to do it
naturally okay we're going to talk about
the first part right here where we're
going to decrease body stress do you
realize that all the stress that you've
ever experienced is stuck in your body
to some degree so stress accumulates
your body is like a sponge and it holds
stress and what I'm going to show you in
this next part is several key things
that you can do to extract stress using
an acupressure device that I created so
let me just go ahead and go right into
it and show you that right now
check it out it's very simple we take
the widest part right here and on your
couch you lean back and you put this
right in the mid part of your neck sit
back and you let gravity push your head
back into this device and you just
before you go to bed for two minutes
we're going to take the longer portion
and press it into some points in the
abdomen about an inch to the right of
your belly button and then we're going
to press directly inwards like this
pressing in right like that and I'm
going to hold this pressure not so it's
very painful but just so this pressure
for about maybe a minute or so and its
releasing stress if this takes the lot
of the flight-or-fight stress out of
your body also in your middle back
that's the second part that's where
you're going to hold all the stress to
because the slider fight mechanism is
located in your mid-back and that's
where you want to work on a lot of
stress also is contained in the
underneath
on the top of the chest and the top of
the heart so that's another technique
that we want to do to extract stress to
the upper upper chest area and then the
back of the upper neck by the skull
where it connects to the neck that's
another place where you hold stress
okay we're back to the second thing
which is increasing the quality of sleep
that you have so we have the quality of
sleep and we have the quantity of sleep
we want to get to the root of it now in
the last section with reducing the body
stress of course that is going to help
you sleep so stress could stop you from
sleeping but there's other causes of
sleep issues as well number one your
bladder at night you're peeing all night
long that's because you have insulin
resistance or maybe a sleep apnea and
you have one of those machines that's a
sinus problem that you have or insulin
resistance so there's many different
things maybe you're missing nutrients
okay but if you go through all these
things and apply some of this stuff
you're going to start sleeping better
and it could be that you just get up
early and you don't let yourself go to
sleep so whatever you can do to enhance
the sleep do it even if you have to take
naps that's going to reduce cortisol
very very important next one increasing
aerobic exercise I'm not talking about
the aerobic exercise that you would do
I'm talking about the type of exercise
which is lots of oxygen low stress and
that would be walking a mild version of
yoga because they have Power Yoga right
now which is extremely exhausting I'm
talking about something that's going to
create a lot of relaxation I like the
long walks will you get a lot of space
that will lower cortisol also there's
low intensity workouts like Pilates very
good for cortisol nutrient wise as far
as vitamins increasing b1 is the key
vitamin for your adrenals and stress b5
is also a key B vitamin support the
adrenals and recovery and vitamin D as
these vitamins go up cortisol will go
down okay number five herbal adaptogens
you can use ashwagandha there's a whole
series of
that you can use I'll put them I'll put
a link down below of what I recommend
but adaptogens can actually lower our
cortisol as well and then increasing the
parasympathetic nervous system if you
haven't watched my videos before maybe
you're not familiar with this word but
the parasympathetic nervous system is
that nervous system that is actively
working to calm you down it opposes the
sympathetic nervous system which is the
flight of fight so it's in the
background chilling you out keeping
things calm but when you lose this heart
rate goes up stress goes up and you're
in a state of flight-or-fight which is
stress so to support this of course all
these are going to do it and also
potassium will do it and magnesium will
do it so you want to start consuming
more potassium magnesium you could do it
through electrolytes you can do it
through greens vegetables it just so
happens that vegetables have the highest
amount and so if you're just eating pure
protein let's see during the Atkins diet
and you're not doing enough vegetables
you're going to get a lot of phosphorous
and not enough minerals to calm the
nervous system down so you're going to
actually have hard time sleeping you're
gonna be more stress if you want to
accelerate the nervous system especially
the flight-or-fight you want to take
phosphorous if you want to chill it out
you want to take potassium magnesium all
right so go ahead and apply these and
put your comments below